ich würde auf jeden fall weiterempfehlen
also für jemanden der interesse daran
hat irgendwie so grundlegende formen die
irgendwie zu lernen wie man sich die
welt erklärbar machen kann oder wie man
irgendwie argumentationen aufbauen kann
das ist sehr nützlich unter zwei
voraussetzungen voraussetzung 1 dem
können und voraussetzungen zu wollen
also ist nicht jeder mann jede frau kann
philosophie studieren
das ist auch wieder eine individuelle
frage weil ich glaube man wird einfach
mit vielen sachen konfrontiert wo man
einfach nicht weiß ob es ist richtiger
ist oder auch nicht und das zweite auf
wollen bezieht sich dann vor allem auf
die frage was machst du dann nach ja mit
philosophie ist ein studium zum
selbstzweck das ist unbestritten und
nicht willst dass du so für dich selbst
zu studiert dann würde ich es nicht
weiterempfehlen also philosophie läuft
natürlich auf kein konkretes berufsbild
hinaus wenn wir dann sagt ich stelle
mich jetzt bei ihnen als die neue haus
und hof philosophie auch wenn man keine
festen berufsaussichten in dem sinne hat
sollte man sich schon darauf einlassen
wenn einige sachen wirklich
interessieren die eben auch wichtig um
einfach ein behandelt werden aber so
prinzipiell wenn ich philosophie voll
gut weil man sich einfach mit themen
befasst die welt relevant sind sage ich
mal mit denen wir tagtäglich kontakt
haben ohne darüber nachzudenken weil ich
denke einfach dass es dass es die
wissenschaft vom leben ist dass es
nichts gibt was mehr am alltag ist oder
überhaupt näher an den problemen der
menschen ich empfehle tatsächlich viel
und philosophie einfach mal für ein zwei
semester zu machen weil es egal welchen
beruf man jemals haben wir die
philosophie immer was was bringt ich
finde es unglaublich wichtig und ich
glaube ich habe in meinem leben nichts
so sehr weiter gebracht wie die
philosophie
ich würde keinem weiterempfehlen der
angst hat was zu lernen